well, it happened in Georgia and we talked
about it, but we covered the Alabama antiabortion
law
earlier this week and now Missouri has passed
another one of these absurdly extreme anti
abortion bills and this bill passed in the
Missouri Senate and what it would do is ban
abortion starting at eight weeks of pregnancy
period.
Remember, many women don't even know that
they're pregnant until five weeks into pregnancy,
six weeks into pregnancy.
There are obviously exceptions that go even
beyond that, but it's very common that until
five or six weeks into pregnancy, uh, a woman
may not know that she's pregnant and this
bill would set a limit for legal abortions
at eight weeks.
The bill now goes back to the house for one
more vote before it would be sent to the Republican
Missouri Governor Mike Parson for a vote into
law and Parson is expected to sign it.
Now, there are some important differences
between this law and others that have been
passed.
One is that this is a law that in its most
extreme form would be triggered by the overturning
of Roe v Wade and otherwise has some slightly
less insane, uh, provisions and limits in
it in terms of exceptions.
There are exceptions in this law for medical
emergencies, but like the Alabama law, no
exceptions for rape, no exceptions for incest
either.
And as far as punishing doctors and or mothers,
mothers, uh, of women who have abortions would
not be prosecuted.
And doctors who perform abortions after eight
weeks could be faced with five to 15 years
in prison.
So once again, it's not so much about this
law specifically, although looking at what
it is that they're doing in the provisions
that are and aren't part of each law is important.
This is all part of the bigger plan that we've
been telling you now about, uh, for months
and in more detail for a couple of weeks and
in more significant detail in the last three
or four shows this week.
This is all part of the bigger plan to get
one of these laws struck down by an immediate
buy, a lower federal court.
And then use the appeal process to try to
get it to the supreme court to really get
a, a, an opportunity that maybe has not been
around for decades to seriously stifle abortion
nationally, either through a sort of implicit
conflict with Roe v Wade or in some scenarios
by actually getting Roe v Wade overturned.
Although as I explained on yesterday's show
overturning Roe v Wade in and of itself is
not necessary for these laws to have an appeal
process ultimately to the Supreme Court, uh,
that could result in the significant limiting
of abortion, uh, federally, not federally
at, uh, an in multiple states as a result
of a federal court's ruling.
And, um, it's important to know that, you
know, Missouri already has one of the strictest
antiabortion laws in the country.
They've got a 72 hour mandatory waiting period.
There's only one abortion clinic in the entire
state.
So when you step back and we see that we had
Alabama earlier this week, we've, we've already
seen Georgia, Kentucky, Mississippi and Ohio
moving forward with abortion bans ones fetal
cardiac activity can be detected, which again
is right around the sixth week of pregnancy,
North Dakota and Iowa tried similar things
so far.
Those have been struck down in court.
The whole point here is pass something so
extreme that it has to be seen as a conflict
with Roe v Wade, which will in the immediate
get a court to strike it down, which will
over the medium to longterm open it to appeal
all the way up to the Supreme Court, which
Donald Trump has had the great fortune.
If you are on his side of being able to report
a point, some very conservative justices to,
and this is going to be a huge fight and it's
yet another reminder of how ignorant that
idea was that Trump and Hillary are going
to be the same.
You know what?
If it's not going to be the person I really
want, it almost doesn't matter whether it's
Trump or Hillary because they're going to
be the same.
Well, listen, I hope anyone who had that idea
now realizes how absurdly ridiculous and wrong
it was.
Hillary would not have put two lunatics on
the Supreme Court who would have systemically
endangered abortion rights across the country
and reinvigorated what we are seeing at the
state level now meant to really repress abortion
rights nationally.
Hillary would not have considered military
action against Venezuela and in Iran, uh,
maybe another place as some people like to
argue.
Um, but the idea that they were both equally
likely to get us into military conflicts come
on.
I mean there's a very long list here, uh,
of countries, uh, that Trump has considered
military action against.
There is a very long list of issues on which
in practice, not in theory, but in practice,
Trump and Hillary would have been very different.
And I hope nobody falls for that nonsense.
Uh, going into 2020 because we are seeing
that the impact is real.
The impact is on people.
This is not theoretical political science.
This is day to day affecting people's lives.